do you still support president putin
of course i support vladimir putin
because vladimir putin is protecting
russia from aggression of united states
who we believe occupy the ukraine after
uh registration the last democratically
elected president of ukraine in 2014
and
uh it's more personal war of jobiden
against vladimir
but i just wonder we'll talk about that
in a minute i just wonder why you would
support a man who has launched this
disastrous war
on ukraine and is now threatening
britain and the west with nuclear
weapons why would you support a man like
that
uh it's strange that your journalists
disinformed that this war continued
already eight years and vladimir putin
sent russian army not to uh start the
war but stole the war which continued uh
in uh ukraine uh during these eight
years and dozens of thousands of people
already have been killed during this war
during this eight years
and uh you may don't know i will inform
you
that uh there are dozens of thousands of
political prisoners in uh ukraine now
you maybe i don't know but
we can talk about war crimes that is
being investigated um by the russians by
the ukrainians
perpetrated by the russians but look i
want just a clarification here that
president putin says that in the event
of attack on terror on the territorial
integrity of russia he would without
doubt respond using all means available
now the clarification is if is putin
suggesting that if ukraine
attacks the areas in the east and the
south of ukraine claimed by russia after
these referendums this weekend would
that be the justification for
nuclear war is that what he's saying
no
well putin will not give the order to uh
attack by nuclear weapons ukraine
because ukraine is uh not
a nuclear country
and uh we respect this status
nevertheless it's led by a repressive
regime vladimir putin uh told about
another thing he told that joe biden and
prime minister of great britain mary
johnson distrust moved the world to the
nuclear war
and uh
how did they do how how have they moved
the war to the nuclear war i don't
understand
it's it's very it's very easy
uh you know
i will inform you that united states
here in britain uh you know use
ukrainian
ukrainians haven't invaded russia the
russians have invaded ukraine the truth
is there's only one person responsible
for the war in ukraine and that is
president
but united states uh imposed occupy
regime to the clinton use there for
their political pose opposite and if you
want to know how democratic it is can
you believe that a 70 percent or people
in ukraine they are russians they speak
russian language and of course they want
to
to there's a children's uh to study by
russian
native language and nearly all of them
want to be ukrainians want to live in
ukraine that is the fundamental point
why do you think they're fighting them
why do you think they're fighting
yeah you know i will tell you the
difference between uh russian and
ukrainians it's not like different
between
english and scottish it's the like
deeply between british and english or
british and scottish well
let me answer this
answer me this mr marcos
answer me this mr markov if things are
going so well in this special operation
as president putin calls it why does he
need to mobilize 300 000 more reservists
isn't it a sign that president putin is
losing this war
uh
russia not losing the war but russia
lost the battle in kharkov region and we
lost something about five seven percent
of the territory which had been taken by
russian you know why it's very easily
maybe you don't know about this but
ukraine uh which have five times less
populations than russia nevertheless
because army
twice more than russia mommy because
ukraine has full mobilization it's a
territorial society but russia had no
any mobilization that's why a russian
army underproved twice less than
ukrainian army and vladimir putin now
has two car exits right the truth isn't
the truth as to why there's been no mass
mobilization
that you
don't you're not confident that your
population
would go along with that we're already
seeing uh demonstrations and protests in
moscow and that's for a partial
mobilization
yeah you know why uh this demonstration
because russia's free country people who
took part in those demonstrations they
would be
arrested by police for for five days but
there are no such imaginations okay
if russia's a free country why am i
watching a few minutes ago the police
carting away
hundreds of people
for protesting um you know that
we're seeing it now if it's a free
country why are you not allowed to
protest something like
uh
a a war
yeah uh yeah you know go to the london
you will see a lot of cases where people
are in
london police also took some pressure
but go to the key and you will see
no any uh protest against mass
mobilization and against war with russia
you know why because russia free country
and ukrainian regime not only is
totalitarian society you personally and
also this is your people your
politicians why do you
foreign why are you preventing
journalists from going there why do you
lock up uh political opponents why is
navalny i mean
are you honestly saying it's a free
country
yeah yeah i already know you saw you
show this picture because journalists
have been there journalists made these
victories and send it to the different
media but it's absolutely impossible to
do it in ukraine because ukraine now is
society
the
totalitarian
of 21st century and no one allowed to
have a real project all of them dozen
thousands listen mr markov
it isn't the truth here that uh
president putin has realized that he's
losing this war things are not going
well
and he's mobilized partial mobilization
of 300 000 more troops but he doesn't
risk
a mass mobilization
because the population would not accept
it
uh
here don't worry uh so he's losing not
war he lost some battle in kharkov
region uh it's one uh secondly of course
ibra putin don't want to have mass
mobilization uh
people because people doesn't like it
it's true
and also
because as rain mentioned uh putin don't
want to make totalitarian society from
russia if russia will be the
society as you told on your media many
times at what protest could be all
protests should be very much suppressed
by today just finally just finally mr
malcolm
i get your point just finally mr markov
you said on radio this morning that
russia would be prepared to launch a
nuclear attack on britain that would
kill a lot of people
what you've just said that wouldn't
happen
so what you're saying now that would
only be in response to a nuclear attack
is that what you're saying let's be
clear about this
oh yes yes i would say very clearly
okay nuclear nuclear war is becoming
more and more close to our families to
our houses and to our bodies all right
it's
because russia under the aggression and
their scenario of shifting to the
nuclear war it's not because like even
putin wants to
okay look we have to leave it there mr
markov uh
i think you've made your point thank you
very much indeed thank you